hello everyone i'm juan williams along
with greg gutville
dana perino jesse waters and katie
pavlidge
it's five o'clock in new york city this
is the five
about three weeks ago we were able to
say that we'll have enough vaccine
supply for adults by the end of
july and i'm pleased to announce today
as a consequence of the stepped-up
process that i've ordered and just
outlined
this country will have enough vaccine
supply i'll say it again
for every adult in america by the end of
may
president biden making that big
announcement about when adult americans
will be able to get the vaccine
the president also setting a date for
when he wants teachers to start
receiving the shots
watch this we want every educator
school staff member child care worker to
receive at least one shot
by the end of the month of march to help
make this happen
starting next week and for a month the
month of march
we'll be using our federal pharmacy
program
to prioritize the vaccination of pre-k
through 12 educators and staff and child
care workers
all that news coming while there is a
troubling cost to schools being shut
down a new report says the demand for
mental health care for teens
is skyrocketing cases of intentional
self-harm spiking 334 percent in august
2020
compared to the previous year and from
april
2019 to 2020 drug overdoses
jumped over 119 percent
anxiety rising 94 depression increasing
84 percent
and take a look at this headline
thousands of students reported missing
from school systems nationwide amid
covet 19 pandemic
states around the country are reporting
a big decline
in the number of students enrolled in
public schools
dana let me begin with you it seems to
me to be huge news the president
i think giving us all some reason for
hope here is by saying that he wants
teachers and child care workers
to get at least one shot by the end of
march what do you think
well okay um i actually find this a
little bit outrageous like i
i think it's i want everyone to get a
vaccine and we are on track as a country
to get that done and look let's credit
both presidents and get that
put that to the side okay that's that's
that's great
this school thing is actually quite
outrageous because
most of the money in this coveted relief
bill does not go
to the schools this year in fact one of
the things that president biden said is
um he wants to pass his rescue plan and
that i have given those schools a road
map
i've asked congress to give them the
tools but the money doesn't even go to
them
not only that the cdc has said until
they were pressured
that kids could be in school right now
and holding
kids hostage in order to get your
bloated cobit relief plan through
seems to me to be really outrageous and
i think there's another reason this is
happening
the white house knows this bill is
starting to fall apart the support for
it is starting to fall apart
president biden needs all 50 democrats
because he's not going to get any
republicans i don't think
he's all those democrats you saw today
the chamber of commerce which had been
quite
supportive now starting to say whoa whoa
whoa wait are you sure about this
there's
too much money in here but when it comes
to the schools
none of us can get back to normal if we
don't have the kids back in school you
think of how many women have had to
leave the workforce
because they have to be the ones and
rightly so like god bless them
they're home being trying to take care
of the kids what does that do to their
career track
what are we going to do for them well
the only thing that we can do for them
is get the kids back in school which we
know that they can do safely
i'm for them getting the teachers to get
a vaccine but look at one of the
counties i think
in there in virginia even when they were
told the teachers would get the vaccine
they wouldn't commit to coming back to
the classroom because then they wanted
to move the goal post and say well then
the children had to be vaccinated
and yet there's no reports of
transmission
from kids to teachers in a lot of places
around the country
kids are in school but a majority of
them aren't and just my last point here
is
do you remember last week when kennedy
was on the show and
she got emotional talking about this
issue of
the mental health problems especially
for teenagers
and some of those numbers one if you
look a little bit more deeply it's
especially that middle teen year you
know those junior high middle school
years
those are the worst hardest years for
any human when they're go when they're
growing up
and adding this is just insult to injury
and i think holding them hostage
in order to get this covert relief bill
done is quite outrageous